So what is quizket he's kid
kissed kiskin is an open source software development kit
for working with quantum computers
at the level of circuits
algorithms and application modules this sdk
allows anyone to program on real quantity computers from
their laptop in two lines of code you can access
several quantum systems ranging from super conducting
to trapped iron cubits want to emulate a quantum computer's
behavior instead change a single line of code
and simulate your quantum circuits on our high performance
simulate kiss get is a tool used by tens of
thousands of people global war all try to
build the future whether your researcher developer
or just looking to get started
kissed it has a number of
features available for your needs
allowing anyone to do things
like building your first quantum circuit
run cross domain quantum out of them
and study fundamental quantum phenomenon
maybe now is the perfect time to get involved yourself
and find all the tools you need
including real quantity machines
and sd k through kisking
and a community that is happy to welcome
and answers any questions you may have along the way
you can get started today
at kiss